Why do people recommend IV vitamin C and is that different?
It is because of dosage.
So I do have an article on the website that says
it's titled Heart Acid Oxidated Stress to Kill Cancer and it discusses this and some videos on that, too.
But in short, oral vitamin C
is always going to be taken unless you're taking really, really high doses of it.
In a form that's well absorbed,
it's at a dose, let's say you're taking a thousand milligrams of vitamin C.
That's a typical dose of vitamin C.
That's a dose that the vitamin C is going to act as an anti-oxidant.
So you're going to have the antioxidant benefits of vitamin C at that dose.
Truth is, if you're taking a thousand milligrams capsule of vitamin C, you'll probably only absorb half of it.
So let's say you're taking three thousand milligrams of vitamin C, you're probably going to absorb half of that.
So you're still only getting 1,500 milligrams.
And you have to really get up past about five grams, 5,000 milligrams for it to actually flip and start functioning as an oxidative agent.
So it's really hard from an oral standpoint to get enough vitamin C in orally and absorbed.
It's not just how much you swallow, it's how much you absorb at one time.
So what person is asked, well, I get 10,000 milligrams of vitamin C, 10 grams a day.
So that's kind of like getting an IV.
Okay, yeah, well, kind of.
If you're taking 10,000 milligrams, you're really probably absorbing about half of that, 5,000 milligrams.
Yeah, I do it over the day, so it doesn't hurt my stomach.
Well, if you're doing it over the course of a day, then it's, you're, then, okay, throw that all out because you're over over six hours, you're getting 5,000 milligrams.
Then it's completely acting as an antioxidant, you have to get it in one dose at that to act as an oxidizing agent.
So there's certain nutrients based upon dose, we need a low dose that will act as an oxidizing as an antioxidant.
So like vitamin C and a lower dose, vitamin E and a lower dose, selenium and a lower dose act as an antioxidant, which is good and can prevent cancer.
But once you have cancer and you take that, you actually could be helping keeping cancer alive.
So you don't want to be taking those things at the normal oral dose.
You have to take it at a much higher dose.
And with vitamin C, you have to get up to five to 20 grams to really get into the oxidative dose of vitamin C.
Once it's oxidative, it's a cancer killer.
So thereby, taking IV vitamin C, which is typically going to start at 15 grams, many clinics will start at 20 grams.
And some clinics will go up to 80 grams.
You're getting a very strong oxidative effect.
So therefore it's acting similar to chemo and killing.
Well, just like so many of the other supplements that I put people on, it's oxidative.
So the supplements that we use for cancer are oxidative.
You don't want to be taking antioxidants.
If you went and got chemo, it works because it's oxidative.
So that's why I took you off vitamin C because the dosage that you could possibly get orally is going to be antioxidant.
It would be negating what we're trying to do.
So we don't want to be taking antioxidants.
So that article, hardocene oxidative stress to kill cancer will help.
You understand that? I have a number of videos where I explained this very same thing.
We want oxidative stress to a cancer.
The benefit of using natural things to create an oxidative stress like vitamin C, like all the things I have you on,
is that it spares healthy cells.
It doesn't do damage to healthy cells, but it will tip over cancer cells and kill them.
The benefit of chemotherapy to cancer patients is that it's oxidative.
So it kills cancer cells.
The negative is it doesn't spare healthy cells.
So that's the downside of chemotherapy.
Chemotherapy is actually far more oxidative than doing IV vitamin C or doing protocell or doing all the stuff that I have everybody on, which is oxidative.
Chemotherapy is even far more oxidative, but the negative is everything's going to catch 22 here.
The negative of chemotherapy is that it doesn't spare healthy cells, meaning it will be damaging to healthy cells.
What if you are doing an alternative approach that's oxidative, it's not going to hurt healthy cells.
So that's the pros and cons.
So it's that oxidative effect that we're trying to obtain and we're staying away from antioxidants.
I realize it's very confusing.
So that's why we make videos and try to explain this.
And that's why we have long posted best try to explain it.
So ask these questions at the, what the zoom call is for is these very questions. So good question.